Voiceover: Let's revisit
the scenario where everyone
is trying to exit country B's currency
and convert it back into country A.
We saw in the last video that if,
just left to its own devices,
if this were to happen,
if lot of Bs wanted to
converted into currency A
and because everyone is
afraid to convert into B now
because they think for whatever reason
the country B is in bad shape,
then you have this imbalance
and if you left it to its own devices,
country B's currency
would become devalued.
You would need more Bs to trade for an A,
which is just another way to
say B's value would go down,
and that could be a bad thing,
especially if it's a pretty steep decline.
Maybe it's a country that needs
to import fuel from the rest of the world.
Maybe they need to import food
from the rest of the world,
and if their currency were
to devalue dramatically,
then imports could become
very, very, very expensive
and so people in that country might have
to pay double for gas and double
for basic necessities like
food and whatever else.
So we played out a scenario
where the central bank
of country B actively tries to intervene
to keep this from happening,
to keep the exchange rate stable,
and so what they do is
they could use reserves,
and I'll do this in blue for country B,
so they could use reserves of
A that they have accumulated
during better times or in previous videos,
depending on how you want to view them,
and they try to balance
out the supply of A's
with the supply of B's by selling
their reserves and buying B's.
So one way to think of it,
they're adding supply of A's
and they're also adding demand for B's.
They're going to sell their reserves
of A and buy their own currency.
And that would work as
long as they have reserves.
They're going to be
able to stabilize things
so that this situation doesn't happen.
But the problem was,
and we talked about it at
the end of the last video
is that they can run out here.
It's not like they can print
another country's currency forever.
They can't print it at all.
They have to accumulate this.
This isn't their own currency.
So they have a finite amount of this.
They could eventually run out.
What is often the case is,
currency speculators see this
and they begin to smell blood.
They see, okay look,
people are trying to exit this currency.
It would devalue if it was
left to its own devices,
but the central bank of
country B is trying to keep it
from devaluing by depleting
its finite reserves of currency A.
So what currency speculators
will start to do is,
well I can go into country
B and I can borrow B's.
So I could literally go
to a bank in country B
and borrow some of the B currency,
and then I could go to
the exchange markets
and try to convert it into A's.
Just off of looking at that superficially,
what's that going to do?
Well this is going to make the situation
even worse for the central bank,
because now you have people actively
that don't even hold B's before
they're going to be borrowing B's
and converting them into A's.
So it's going to create
an even larger supply
of B's and even more demand
for the finite number
of A's that are willing to go this way.
And why is the speculator doing this?
Well think about the
two situations for them.
Let me draw the two scenarios.
Scenario one is that for
whatever reason the central bank
of B is able to keep
the currency stabilized.
So currency stays stable.
And the other scenario is that
the central bank runs out of reserves,
and they have to essentially
just let the currencies float,
and B gets devalued.
So central bank out of reserves,
which would mean that the currencies
would float and B would devalue.
Well if this first scenario happens,
and it's happens, and it's going to become
less and less likely as
more and more people pile on
this strategy and more and more people try
to run out of B's or try
to exit B's currency.
But even if this situation were to happen,
the speculator says okay,
the currency ended up being stable.
I'll just unwind this.
I'll take my A's, when I have
to pay off my debt in B's,
I'll take my A's, convert them
into B's and pay off my debt.
And so depending what the interest rates
and all of that were,
not a big loss or maybe
even a minimal loss,
and only if there's a kind of differential
with interest rates or things like that,
minimal to no loss.
But what happens if the central
bank runs out of reserves?
Remember just the fact
that the speculators
are doing this speculative attack,
they're borrowing in country
B and converting to A,
that's making the central bank
run out of reserves even faster.
It's going to deplete their reserves.
Essentially when they do this,
it's the central bank of country B
that's going to be giving them,
is going to be allowing them to convert.
They don't know who they're
buying these B's from with
this A currency they have.
So if this happens,
if the central bank runs out of reserves,
it floats, and then B devalues,
then those currency speculators
make a pretty good buck.
and just to see how that could work,
imagine that they borrow 100 B's,
so this is what they borrow,
and while the currency is
being actively intervened
with by the central bank,
they're trying to keep it from devaluing,
the exchange rate is one A for one B,
so they convert on the open market,
and the only reason this is able to happen
at this exchange rate is
because B's central bank
is actively selling A's,
they're able to convert to 100 A's.
Now let's say that they're able to do this
and the central bank runs out of A's
and then a devaluation occurs.
So this is happening at a
conversion of one A equals one B.
But let's say that these guys,
they run out of reserves.
The things devalue.
B becomes worth a lot less,
and then we go to a future state
where one A is now equal to two B's.
Well as soon as this happens,
and remember this is this
scenario right over here
that we're thinking about right over here,
this is what the currency
speculators want to happen.
If one A all of a sudden equals two B's
because the central bank
can't intervene any more,
they are floating, B gets devalued.
Then what's going to happen?
These guys can take their 100 A's.
Convert it back once things are floating.
So now they're going to convert
back into this direction.
And how many B's can they convert it into?
Well now they can convert it into 200 B's.
They can pay off their debt
because they borrowed the 100 B's,
so minus 100 B's to pay debt,
and then they make a
pretty sizable profit.
They make a profit of 100 B's.
That's exactly what they're hoping for,
and so you can imagine
this is one of those trades
that they're going to try to get more
and more people to do,
because the more people that jump
on the band wagon and do
this exact same strategy,
the faster the central bank's reserves
are going to deplete,
and the more likely that this situation
right over here plays out.